all right
good day baby
um welcome back
or welcome forward
I don't know where you are
um but I'm happy to be here it's uh we
got a fire episode today
um we got a lot of calls have come in we
haven't done a solo episode in a while
you know so it's about time I feel like
and
um just a lot of just beautiful
information and Intel
to get into and just
I mean it's just a damn little Christmas
I feel like in September today we're
back together we got Dalton is going to
be calling in you remember Dalton that
beautiful little rail monkey he got hit
by that train a while back and he got
trained out baby and um we were grateful
he's he's gonna call him we're gonna
have him on the line and talk to a real
human miracle
and see what that's like to just get
that close baby I mean just get on the
damn fingertips of the Lord we're gonna
find out
um I'm grateful to be here with you guys
and I mean that and uh
let's get into it
[Music]
well I just broke up with my baby
[Music]
gonna come up
that right there baby if you like that
little that warmer
if you like to just set your damn ear
kettles on that warmer baby that's Eddie
nine volt on the come up
and that's what I gotta remind myself
because there's two ways to go baby
there's two ways to go and I gotta
remind myself
I'm on the come up
and so are you happy September
as we migrate into the future we are
just I mean damn we're just like a worm
just eat just you know worms just eat
the dirt
did you know that a lot of people are
like well how does how does the dirt get
from the front of the worm to the bag of
the worm the worm eats the dirt
and duties the dirt through the back
and that's what we're doing baby
were those [ __ ] time worms baby we're
just
we're just cruising baby
we're cruising cruising through time
together out here
um
and it's happening fast man it happening
fast
hell you put your heat you put your ear
up to the
you put your ear up to the Future you
can hear the date you know
you put your ear up to the wind you
could hear the damn trick-or-treaters
getting ready
you could hear somebody pop you know uh
dusting off a damn Dracula mask
you could hear somebody whipping up a
pot of fake blood maybe people are
getting ready
this is it's happening man it's Autumn
you know the tree's about to get naked
dog that's that's pretty crazy when you
think about it
all summer and all spring the trees are
like oh I'm wearing this I'm wearing
this
and then bam boy all them [ __ ] out
there in a damn wood orgy
there are things out there man
all these birds thought they're hiding
suddenly you see them [ __ ] they're
like oh [ __ ]
we better fly to Florida
it's that time baby it's that time you
know I really I do enjoy this time of
year I enjoy when you go from that
there's that week where it's like still
hot and then bam
surprise you wake up one morning
and you feel winter just you know
because Autumn is just winners little
[ __ ] uh puppy that's all it is
that's just winter taking a damn little
little dog for a walk that's all Autumn
is
automate some automatic lasts a half
hour in some places
you go up to Maine you go up to damn uh
and or another anata Rico what is it and
not Eureka
no
what's the top of the country called to
the whole globe
that's Antarctica baby Antarctica
you go to Antarctica baby that's fall
lasts about nine minutes up in that
bastard that's a quick you know damn you
can't even finish your coffee son
them winners there boy that thing will
eat your ass bro
that thing will eat your ass with nine
Knuckles baby
um
what's happening A lot's been going on
uh
we haven't done a solo episode in a
while
um
we're out here in the central East
uh we have uh we've had an exciting run
of guests recently
we just had um
uh Tony cannon on and he is a Indy car
driver and he's from Brazil
and uh got to go riding out with
Mario Andretti he took me for a scoot
out in uh in one of his damn little bus
buggies baby we were out there
we hit about I think 200 something miles
an hour
I mean I could [ __ ] I could taste the
the enamel in the back of my throat that
on from my own teeth bro that [ __ ]
really that [ __ ] will clear your sinuses
bro high speed
um
what else we got to we went down to Joe
Rogan came on the podcast if you didn't
hear that episode that was pretty cool
that was really pretty cool man he uh he
had been texted me and and invited me to
go on his show
and I was like yeah thanks I'd love to
come and then I was like well I know I
got a space on mine that week I said and
I was kind of nervous to text but I was
like uh maybe you you should we'd love
to have you on ours and um and so that
was exciting
uh got to go and do that Bobby Lee came
on
that beautiful little
unagi bro that little uh
that little Vietnam Survivor you know
and sometimes boy I [ __ ] just
that little ponzoo little Muppet son was
at a spot man I'll take that dude I'll
drop him off at every damn VFW in
America
and let some old boys in there finish up
on him you know what I'm talking about
ewo Jima Daddy
praise God brother
um
what else has been happening with me
uh oh we got to shoot a film we shot a a
movie
or a film
movie film movie
uh we shot we shot that that was
interesting
you know at first I didn't really want
to do it
um
because it's a lot of time it's just a
lot of time
and
and I don't like giving up my time
honestly
it's a pretty selfish way to be
it's nice that sometimes you have to do
it
but I don't like uh sometimes I I just
want to keep I kind of you know I want
to keep my time to myself
you know I gotta keep my time all in
like a little you know
I'm that little second Santa I got all
my seconds in a bag on my back baby
and I might you know you know take that
Satchel off and get a minute out to
somebody
give seven eight minutes to a little
dime a little Dame a little beauty over
there
maybe give you know four or five minutes
to your boy over there
but otherwise I like to keep my time to
myself man
so for me that was a new experience just
saying okay I don't know what this is
going to be like I'm gonna commit to
doing it
uh
and so and I was glad that I did man we
just had a nice time
um
I got to do like this kind of like
that fighting scene but it was like this
kind of like like wrestling kind of
scene with Johnny Knoxville
and uh
and that was you know
I thought it would be all I'm thinking
like all right how do I look like angry
but I'm I'm fighting or I'm you know you
know do I make like a face and I'm just
thinking of all this like what will I do
you know
well I S you know do I have to be real
lagged do I need to you know call
somebody and you know call him a [ __ ]
or something first or well I just feel
angry like how will I make it all work
and we got there and it just everything
rolled out pretty cool
you know I didn't
I didn't uh
I didn't
overanalyze it too much just did it and
Bobby Lee was there so that made it a
lot of fun just getting to be around him
every day
because he's um newly single you know we
saw he him and his lady
you know they went their separate ways
and so he's you know I mean he's most of
the day he's on the
just
hunting leg on the uh phone and internet
I mean damn
that dude he had people he he had put
some calling out on his
social media on his podcast for you know
I guess women ascending pictures of tits
and you know
Cooter or whatever booty booty Cooter
all of it I don't even know
um and damn men were sending him stuff
and so he didn't know until each time he
click on the picture and sometimes I
said damn you know that you know it'd
just be one long tit you know with some
nuts on him like damn bro
that's a damn G cup that thing that
thing's a that's a unique looking tit
because he was getting sent everything
um
but that was a nice experience I'm glad
that I did it
um
and what else man we went oh I went and
visited my brother out there in Utah
and it was in southern Utah
right by Mount Zion Park and it is I
mean it's
it is beautiful man
it's like Mother Nature's um
you know uh
whatever it's called strip club I mean
if she got her finest
everything it just every Mount Every
Mountain Hill every little
thing it's just damn it's fine as hell
bro
you know you just want to suck your own
nuts bro it's just it's just that kind
of place Mountain Zion if you get a
chance to go there
um and my brother had moved out there he
lives in Springville or Springdale
right outside of the park or Rockville
and he'd um
we had some fresh raccoon he shot a
couple of coons out there
and so we had uh some fresh raccoon
squirrel
Dove and I'd eaten Dove before
um you know when I was young I had a
couple brothers that lived by the
apartments and they grilled up a couple
doves one time
for Mother's Day
and I had some of that with them
what else uh
what else do we do
yeah that's just kind of what's been
going on uh just thank you guys for
staying supportive of the cast and
keeping um and keeping things going
um I still got my sober days going right
now I have let me see
feeling pretty good look on my little
app
I have a 156 days
so that's been nice
uh to just you know feel a part of
something
yeah and it's been interesting man in
going to those meetings and stuff you
know uh
and just hearing other people talk
honestly
you know sometimes
when other people speak real real
honestly
about themselves about what's going on
with them
it allows me to think honestly about
what's going on with me
it's like sometimes I can't really it's
hard for me to get a clear perception of
myself
um or to think really like
real clearly unless there's but
sometimes in the recovery meeting some
if somebody's sharing real honestly
about what's going on with them then I
can
I don't know my brain just feels or my
emotions just feel safe to like
give me like a real insight into what's
going on with me
so a lot of times real nice to go to
those meetings and just listen
you know and just hear
and it's funny because sometimes people
will put into words what I could I can
never it's like
I'll have little pieces of of what I'm
trying to feel
but I can't get the Mosaic right you
know I can't get the
I can't get it to really Jang up
and then somebody else will they'll say
it and they'll have just I mean they put
all my pieces together it's like oh man
thank you so much I've just had these
pieces you know
um
so that's one thing that I really love
about the meetings
um
what else I want you guys to hit the
hotline and just I want to know who's
listening to this show
um just tell me what you do it doesn't
have to be really long you know
um this is Ricky and I work at a uh you
know I work at UH
Build A Bear you know I'm a associate or
you know I'm a uh
fur Handler whatever it is do it you
know and just hit the hotline leave that
and we just I'd love to know who's um
who's listening
um
I feel nervous I haven't done this kind
of like a solo episode in a while
so I don't know why I feel nervous about
it but
uh that's okay it also could be
excitement
sometimes nerd excitement like hot like
it's we think it's nerves but it's just
like
it's just excitement
you know I think we get we immediately
sometimes are I immediately so now we'll
say I'm it's anxiety but [ __ ] I might
just be a little psyched up about it you
know it's been a while it's been a while
since I've gotten to sit here and uh
and be in this seed and and um and be a
part of this program so I'm grateful for
that
all right let's get into a little bit of
news here we got some news that has come
in
um I thought this was pretty fascinating
Florida Governor defends migrant flights
to Martha's Vineyard suggests more to
come so here's what happened is uh
DeSantis
who is a governor in Florida
and I always think it's interesting how
like if somebody there's a problem
somewhere people don't know about it
elsewhere but they'll have an idea about
it they'll be like oh well this is what
they should do this is what they should
do but you until it's right there with
you then it then suddenly it's you get a
real concept of what the issues are
so that's why I think this is pretty
fascinating I mean it's definitely a
little bit a little bit gangster to be
using humans and shifting them around
um
but
it's interesting now that it's suddenly
a Martha's Vineyard you just imagined us
you know 50 low-key just loked out
[ __ ] uh
uh visitors just hanging out
that's the part to me that see because I
love anything that bothers [ __ ] rich
people I love that [ __ ] if you could
bother the rich man if you could [ __ ]
tickle the rich with dirty fingernails
[ __ ] I love that [ __ ]
so I think anytime you can drop off a
couple of essays
um up in Martha's Vineyard baby let's do
it that's what I'm saying
you know you got MS-13 suddenly you got
mv13 baby you got Martha's Vineyard 13
baby
you know that's my shit's gonna get
weird
so yeah I just because then people get
to see what what issues are like
um we had a border patrol agent on here
at one point I remember
and he was in charge of the Arizona
border
uh
for a long time
I can't remember how long maybe 17 years
and he was saying one of the biggest
problems on the board was that people
were coming over good people and bad
people
were coming over and they weren't
prosecuted like even if they arrested
the people like two weeks later they
were coming right back because there was
no like legislation happening where they
were actually like the executive branch
wasn't Prosecuting them
and you don't until you talk to somebody
who's from there you don't really have a
good idea of what's going on
um so that's why I like this I wish
there was like buses of different
problems from different areas that were
just kind of cruising around the country
and they dropped somebody else's problem
off in your area for a while and then
they take your problems and drop them
off of an air then they take um
you know like in Maine maybe they got
beached whales or something issue and
then they dropped them [ __ ] off in
Idaho and they're like damn bro you know
and and I just think it would be
interesting if different buses were just
just like oh [ __ ] here come this [ __ ]
trouble bus and you see whose problem it
is today you know like damn
they got uh
you know
um like women aren't shaving under their
arms in Oregon or whatever or in like
you know somewhere and then them [ __ ]
get out you're like dang bruh I didn't
know it was like that
so I think it would be interesting if
there was a whole system of this going
on
so that's something that I think I would
like to see in the future is just like a
whole kind of uh
different issues from different areas
kind of cruising around that way
everybody could get a little bit of a
taste
and see because then when you vote on a
national level and you have an idea of
your whole country
you get like a real idea
of
what real of what people's issues are
you know and for me a lot of that stands
people talk about racism all the time
and um
and they're like what you know I'll hear
people like in California talk about
like the South uh but they've they've
they're not they didn't they didn't grow
up in South they don't understand some
of the intricacies and like the boots on
the ground
um every day
uh
uh existence of living in a place that's
had a lot of racism
um or black and white racism maybe and
so I think sometimes that's crazy to me
it's like well but you don't know you
don't live you don't have an
understanding you know you may have like
a vision of it
and information but until you get that
understanding
so I like that man maybe it's just some
understanding buses that's not it it's
not like a problem bus it's like okay
here comes some understanding buses
we're about to understand this [ __ ] you
know and then it drops off and it's like
a surprise you're like oh [ __ ] man
uh so I don't know I think that that
could be pretty interesting mint mobile
if you don't know about it
you may want to learn it's a good way to
save money offering premium Wireless
starting at just 15 dollars a month
and now for the plot twist nope
there isn't one
mint mobile just has premium Wireless
for 15 bucks a month
no trapping you into a two-year contract
or opening the bill to find all these
crazy fees none of that
if you hate your phone bill mint mobile
gives you the best rate whether that
you're buying for one or a family
and that meant families start at two
lines
use your own phone with any mint Mobile
plan
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5G Network get
premium Wireless for just 15 bucks a
month and no one expected plot twists at
mintmobile.com
t-h-e-o that's mintmobile.com
Theo seriously you'll make your wallet
very happy at mintmobile.com
Theo you know the best time to prepare
for growth is before the opportunity
arises
that's what ship station is here to help
with
you know I set up a ship station uh
before things got too busy so that
orders could get out correctly and
merchandise could get to people
no more limiting your business to just
one store ship station integrates with
every platform including Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify Etc
making it easy to manage all your
shipping from one simple dashboard
save time with Consolidated order
management and automated shipping
updates for your customers they do it
all ship station
you can compare carriers rates and
delivery times to get the most out of
every send yep 98 98 of companies that
use ship station for one year become
customers for life it's worth trying go
to shipstation.com today and sign up
with the promo code Theo for a free
60-day trial
start today and get set up before the
biggest shipping season of the year
that's two months free visit
shipstation.com Click the microphone at
the top and type in code Theo ship
station make ship happen
a little more news here
um the uh female orgasm that gas em baby
that uh that Betty bust you know what
I'm talking about
um it says female emission that orgasm
you know these are talking about women
that's uh those Gunners baby you know
them ejaculators some women they'll damn
you know what I'm saying they could
really uh
they really you know they got that
that freaking uh
they got that that Cooter Gleek you know
what I'm talking about these women are
squirters they call them Gunners I don't
like using that kind of language but
they're real Gunners baby
you know what I'm saying though damn uh
they got that bidet just built into
their you know
but dussy you know what I'm talking
about they just
um you know the damn they could wash off
the back of a moth
at probably [ __ ] eight feet
but the female emission had orgasm uh is
confirmed in a new study
that uh the fluid that is released is
from the bladder
there's long been a lot of chatter over
the years
um that it was you know female you know
they had like a special
you know you know semen pocket in them
or something I don't know
but uh or that it was tea it was like a
lot of women you know have a lot of
Tears built up in them and then they
just gun out all these tears at you but
a lot of us knew that it was urine
I mean it was urine and so there's a new
study that was done if you haven't heard
about this and this is uh the
international Journal of Urology
um it says five women two in their
thirties two in their 40s and one in
their 50s dang baby
dang
grandma got that super Soca
they participated in this study all
women were able to
uh squirt they was these gunners
and three of them
gunned out uh with sexual stimulation
and two of them with penetrative sexual
stimulation
so one of them was just kind of reading
the Braille or two of them were just
reading the Braille and the other one
was and the other three were using the
pencil
um and what they did was they injected
the women with a blue dye into their
bladders so they they could tell what
what was what or they drained them first
it says
um a catheter was inserted before sexual
stimulation and the bladder was emptied
so they drain these babes
and then a mixture of indigo
and saline was injected into the bladder
um
sexual stimulation was provided
and it was videotaped and verified some
perv out there running this deal
and uh the secretions were collected in
sterile cups and it was found the main
component of uh squirt fluid is urine
urine
so there you go we knew it was uh piss I
say piss or PP but I say piss also
mostly
uh we knew it was piss and it is
if you didn't think it was Fizz I think
you're a real Crave You
you knew it was piss it was Peace So
anyway
um
yeah that's what women have been doing
they've been pissing
uh secret that's really a secret it's a
tops you know it's a real it's that back
up bladder though damn you got that
that thing really somebody can water a
plant you know or just dampen a
you know dampen a damn uh
I knew this one gal she could dampen
probably an eighth of a loaf of
Pepperidge Farm bro this [ __ ] really
had that
she had that baby hose backed up in her
all right so that's a little bit of news
um what else
I want to let you know that um October
4th through 7th coming up at a Lexington
Kentucky
over there they got beautiful broads and
horses and women
um October 11th Wichita Kansas uh I
believe that sold out they're almost
gone for the second show they're October
13th and 14th Omaha and Denver
those are sold out we will add some more
dates for those but it won't be until
the spring November 3rd through 6th in
San Diego at the Balboa theater
um I think the fifth show is up now we
sold out four shows thank you guys so
much
uh it's just man I'm really excited and
it's gonna be it's gonna be great I'm
excited to be back up there and and get
out and see you guys all those available
theovan.com
t-o-u-r a new story came out about the
25 most dangerous jobs based on data
from the bureau Bureau of Labor
Statistics
um
so I peeped these up and the number five
one was garbage collectors
you don't think about it as being that
dangerous but you know that truck likes
to Chomp that truck will eat anything I
think we eat a damn baby stroller that
[ __ ] will eat an ex-wife if you you
know
if you you know did something wrong to
her you know uh so you know that thing
doesn't really have much of a conscience
on it
and it it also people throw a lot of you
know semi bad food out in the garbage
so I'm sure you're cruising on the back
of that thing somebody threw a batch of
bad shrimp in there
and at first if you're like me if you're
in a car you see some food or something
you're like I'm not gonna have any but
for some reason three minutes later I'm
eating it
doesn't matter what it's like that
gardetto's or whatever that [ __ ] I hate
it
you put a bag by me I look at it I say I
hate that
three minutes later I'm eating it I'm
eating these little [ __ ] toasts made
for damn elves or whatever I'm eating
I'm making a little [ __ ] sandwiches
putting a little peanut between I'm
eating it
so I can imagine it's the same thing
when you're out back there you you know
you're hiding on the back of that g
truck they always got two freaking uh
little recycle bunnies hanging off the
back of that [ __ ]
and
and you forget somebody you know tall
you know somebody threw in some bad
shrimp you out there a mile later you
[ __ ] have two of them
next thing you know you
you six feet under the sea baby that's
it bad shrimp take anybody out a king or
a pauper
so I could really see how that is uh the
number five job
that is um unhealthy for people
the number four most toughest uh most
dangerous job roofers it says right here
roofers
um you know them little lid monkeys baby
if you
that's if you want to put a top on
something they're trying to they're
trying to shut everything down and close
everything in if you're a roofer
uh I remember we used to invite this one
kid over to play uh to play at the house
and me and my buddy we would call him
and invite him he live across the street
but then we'd get up on the roof with a
couple pellet guns and uh just spice
them up spice his skin up when he walked
over
and he he already had this little fella
had some uh he wasn't little but he was
he has some bone density deal going on
and uh
so partum was little and partum was big
you know he was just kind of that little
um that little wobble rabbit you know
that little shake it like a sausage you
know he just had that built into him and
uh and we're still all friends and [ __ ]
it was just childhood [ __ ] but if we
didn't have a roof that kind of [ __ ]
don't happen
so I'm not shocked that Roofing gets
real real dangerous overall
number three we have uh Derek operators
in oil and gas mining
and that doesn't surprise me That's
dangerous because
I mean natural gas that's basically
mother that's Mother Nature has got a
it's just a fart that's hiding inside of
Mother Nature
that's all it is man natural gas all
that is man
so you telling me say you're laying
somewhere right and some dude rolls up
with a needle and sticks it in your body
and tries to suck a damn
butt puff right out of you bro
dude I beat the elbows off that dude
he won't be able to hug anybody he won't
be able to hug correctly for damn 18
months
so that's all Mother Nature look that's
danger if you're trying to just you know
suck a big dirt puff right out of Mother
Nature's abdomen then you get you get
sideswiped by her or whatever
I'm not surprised she's beating people's
asses and and really causing hell and
causing fatal accidents as fatal
accidents
so they don't shock me man any creep
trying to suck something out of Mother
Nature's gut is a real freak I think
they are real booty freak nature Style
this is uh I can't tell if it's getting
born to me or not but number two uh
aircraft pilots and it says private
helicopter and aircraft Pilots
and I think the the issue with them why
it could be dangerous because there's
not as much with commercial pilots
there's more
checks and balances there's other Pilots
that they are all going to the airport
with and
but private you just call your guy hey
I'm ready to go you know we're leaving
in eight hour leaving in three hour
leave you know and he could be doing
anything he could be hopped up on a
couple blue shoes half an eight ball
whatever
so now next thing you know he's up there
he's navigating you know the rich then
that's the rich man
if you get rich it gets risky
you know there's a cost to beat a boss
and
and so that's what I think they get they
get these Pilots that they're ready to
go but they could have been up to no
good right before
so you get some dude up there he's still
all you know geeked up
on some of that [ __ ] uh
on some of that nose broth baby you know
what I'm saying liquid cocaine
and
he's he's on damn hinge up there he's
swiping on matches
and next thing you know he just swipes
your [ __ ] Learjet in the side of a
mountain
so I think that that's the issue with
that I would imagine
and the last one here is logging workers
login workers I mean you just get a re a
lot of a lot of people that are trying
to stay off the grid
a lot of people
um and it's not really the tree you got
to worry about that much
because a tree only has two moves it has
one it has the fall
and then the real most dangerous move of
a tree the role
people don't think about that [ __ ]
people yell timber and it falls then it
[ __ ] rolls over nine people
because they don't have a nobody thought
of another thing for after timber that's
really just ignorance
so you get that Timbre but you don't get
that double up on the roll people
getting damn rolled out you know all of
a sudden you know [ __ ] step dance
flat and y'all poor
so it's just
you know they don't have a good plan for
that I think with logging and the
secondary issue is this man a lot of
Cree a lot of just
crawdad humans out there I work with
this dude Ronnie bro
and they call them big hat Ronnie and he
was a brother and he had mental
retardation
and me and him got hired and um
I was supposed to be the boss but he
didn't understand what that meant so
you know when he was bigger than me
anyway and so we were both [ __ ] we're
about you know we're out there doing
work for my buddy Richard who actually
died but
we're out there and Heat this dude bro
once they lit that saw up they gave him
that [ __ ] he [ __ ] cut everything bro
this dude cut [ __ ] bird feeders in
half cutting [ __ ] fences open didn't
give a [ __ ] he cut open a damn chain
link fence bruh
this dude man we he probably hit four
trees in about maybe half an afternoon
that's due to cut a new [ __ ] bathroom
into your [ __ ] kitchen this dude
didn't give a [ __ ] bruh
so and he loved the uh Lakers he loved
the Lakers I remember that
and I hope he's doing well too
and he'd walk to work that dude leave
for work at 4 30 and get to work at
[ __ ] seven bro
and do walk to work
just greased out natural God's grease
baby sweat
and he just like wants that [ __ ] gas
fumes hit him in that [ __ ] little
baby that little just that spinning
scissor sword bro he [ __ ] cut
anything
[ __ ] cut the damn Earth open dude he
didn't give a [ __ ] bruh
so I can see how logging is dangerous
because the trees and then the people
you're doing it with they're [ __ ]
what else we got some great calls that
came in in the hotline as always
985-664-9503
um we've had some good
good calls that came in here we go
hey Theo so I've been thinking
um I've been single about nine months
now my fiance cheated on me with
um a dude so I obviously broke that off
thought I was disgusted but so he
the thing that gets me right he says
that it was only sexual and that
since it wasn't emotional it's not gay
I don't understand what do you think for
me I think it's [ __ ] gay if he's a
[ __ ] which I guess he said he was
and he has a penis it's gay right
definitely gay
and maybe if they transitioned and hunt
the vagina but it's not but I don't know
just a question that's kind of eating me
up what um thank you for the call first
of all uh and I'm sorry you're going
through this and I appreciate you
sharing it I think this is a big Topic
in America right now and in the entire
world
um I think what your boyfriend or your
your male
boyfriend or whatever I think what he's
doing is called considering gay or
attempted gay
because it's not really I'm going to go
and be gay and do gay
it's more like I'm gonna he's kind of
just
he's just wandering into the car wash a
little you know
he just kind of looking at the different
sponges and seeing how you know
different things soak and how the suds
kind of roll off at different edges and
things it seems like
um
and so I don't know if that's gay you
know because he might like to some guys
like that I hear a lot about it you
would be surprised
I hear a lot about men they like the
titties and they like to have that
little wand kind of wandering around
that little door stop on it you know
because a lot of um
trans
penises aren't fully functional
and you can correct me if I'm wrong
because I don't know anything
but a lot of trans uh people's penises
they're not fully functional penises
they are kind of part-time wieners or
they are
some of them are not functional it's
just like mistletoe for the for that
b-hole baby for that butthole
so it's just a little bait and then you
you know you hit him with that b-hole
baby
um so
maybe he could just be super curious you
he may want you to do some new stuff he
may want you to put on a fake wiener or
fake um
dick
and
do something with them you know or hit
him with some fake dicks or something
while y'all are having sex I don't know
I don't know what he might want
um
you know
you could I don't know you could write
dick on your arm and [ __ ] hit him
with it
I don't know what kind of stuff he's
into I don't know but it doesn't seem
like he's just trying to be gay it seems
like he's just kind of
just
you know I'll say it like this when I
was when I was young they had everybody
went to the water fountain
but there were some guys
that would go to the water fountain and
they would put their mouth on the thing
and they would just take it all
they didn't want to miss nothing
they didn't want to miss a damn drop
they would suck it right off the [ __ ]
machine you could hear the machine
squeal a little sometime if a big guy
got on it
so you might just have a and I don't
know if those men grew up to be gay
or if they just like to get all the
data's like to get their water different
so you might not have a gay man you just
might have a man who likes to drink a
little different than you
um
so it might just be more conversation
you need to have with this gentleman
um
because if anything he's just sound like
a real Curious man
but uh but I wish you the best of luck
it's hard out there
uh it's hard for everybody who's you
know looking for love it's just a it's a
real lost and found too especially as we
get older you're like damn
you know this sweater has blood in it
you know you're like what is it's just
it gets dicey
uh we got a call here
um let's take this one here we go
uh Hey Theo this is Dylan
um I'm in the U.S army
and I just want to let you know I'm a
normal man
and that's it love you brother
well
that's good man
I think that's
I think it's I think it's really good I
guess
you know and I appreciate that call too
Dylan
Normal Man
what is that
Dylan is a normal man
I don't I have I know I've introduced
myself to women like that and it's that
is a scary they don't like that
hey I'm a normal man they don't like or
hey I'm not a bad guy you know some of
that kind of it's not a good way to do
it with the women
I've found
you know I remember one time I followed
this woman in San Francisco for like
four blocks
and I finally caught up to her this fast
woman
I finally catch up to her and I was like
hey I'm not like a creeper or pervert or
something and she [ __ ] flipped out
dude
and I was trying to just
you know talk to her but
I don't know I've never even been in
that City before and also you know who
spilled wine on me
uh uh he used to play quarterback
who are some former quarterbacks Trevin
if you can look it up for the um San
Francisco 49ers
Mark Purdy nope Trey lace Jimmy
Garoppolo okay someone does not follow
football no previous
earlier
who y'all got after Joe in there
Steve Young nope Jeff Garcia Jeff Garcia
here we go Jeff Garcia spilled wine on a
damn new brand new Banana Republic lime
green button up I had
and [ __ ] was fire and I was so excited
to wear it and
and he spilled wine on a pretty nice
wine I thought uh malbat
okay thank you Dylan
take care of yourself Buddies
take care of yourself
um here we got a uh call right here
hey Theo man I've got this I've got this
topic this story I just need to get off
my chest and it's it's [ __ ] in your
pants in front of a female and it's
happened to me a couple times but one
one time I really remember we had some
Panda Express the night before and I'm
I'm just getting to know her you know a
couple dates and uh everything's good
you know in in the night and I wake up
in the morning for work I'm like man I
gotta I gotta relieve this pressure in
my bowels but I'm late for work I don't
know this girl that well I don't do that
to her bathroom so I leave and I get
about halfway to my car and I'm like
yeah this was a mistake
um I don't know what to do now I'm
looking around for a shrub or whatever
but we're in a shrub
what are you in Zelda or something
onward apartment complex so there's
there's not much cover to get around so
I'm thinking man I just gotta I gotta do
it right here by my door so I'm looking
around while I'm looking around about to
do it she comes walking out on the on
the like on the deck or whatever you
know waving my phone at me hey you left
your phone dummy so I'm like [ __ ] I
start walking over there and I get about
halfway through I'm like [ __ ] throw it
down throw it throw the phone down to me
I don't know
throw it down no just come up here silly
I'm like no [ __ ] throw the phone down
now there's nothing worse than when
someone calls you silly when you have to
[ __ ]
there's not it it's like
do you there is nothing silly about me
lady
I am going through
I am
reenacting that movie 300 right now in
my pants and you know you're [ __ ]
calling me so hey silly you don't want
your food
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] one of your windows
open okay onward because I'm you know
yelling at her I'm not going up these
steps I'm just seeping seepage coming
out she comes down finally gives me a
hug gives me my phone oh bro is there
bro if you let somebody hug you
while you have [ __ ] yourself dude you
you sir are messed up man
you're a messed up dude bro and I don't
say that kind of stuff to people a lot
but that's insane man
letting somebody hug you while you've
[ __ ] on yourself
let that write that down
and then read it a couple times
Jesus I'll turn around
and I'm sure she saw those skid marks
yep
huh
I look
I think it's your issue Bob
that's what I think
I think you gotta I don't know what you
gotta do man I got no suggestion for you
bro
Dear God
oh
oh I can't now it just makes me scared
to hug anybody and you're doing that to
people dude but be well
you know one thing that gets me
sometimes in nightmares
I'll be laying there I'll be shut down
and Bam
the devil sends some thoughts
the devil sends a story
I don't want that
it's the same thing with my uh credit
cards if I have a high balance that
thing's just Milling around
it's just
spooking me all the time
if High interest rates are making it
hard to make a dent in your credit card
debt it may be time to rethink your
options
keep more money in your pocket while
paying your credit cards off faster with
a low fixed rate loan from light stream
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience and that's exactly what they
deliver
you can get loans from five thousand to
one hundred thousand and there are
absolutely no fees plus the rate is
fixed so it will never go up over the
life of the loan
just for our listeners apply now get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more
the only way to get this discount is to
go to lightstream.com
t-h-e-o that's l-i-g-h-t
s-t-r-e-a-m.com slash Theo subject to
credit approval rates range from 5.73
APR to 19.99 APR and include a point
five zero percent auto pay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply
and offers are subject to change without
notice visit lightstream.com Theo for
more information you know you only have
so much scan on your body
it's one of those things you get a
limited amount
of acreage
so you gotta you gotta care for it you
gotta do that
yard care
you want to keep it looking healthy
keep the soil looking fresh geology
can help
I use a nice moisturizer at night and
they get you a little deal of it and I
squirt it and I do it
it makes me feel some type of way
but in the morning I wake up dang I see
my smell self smile I say hey boy hey
geology
award-winning skin hair and body
products
yep it's a 13-time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in men's health Esquire and
ask men grooming Awards they've won them
five thousand plus five star reviews
geology skin care helps you fight acne
reduce oilness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes
and have smoother hydrated skin maybe
you want to keep that hydrated it's
important
all geology products are made with
scientifically proven ingredients
trusted by dermatologists and cosmetic
chemists
they offer the everyday face wash the
vital morning face cream
for the am and the PM you can do the
everyday face wash that nourishing eye
cream dang get your Lookers just flossed
up
and that repairing night cream dang wake
up looking like dang Oxana by you baby
or somebody beautiful
use code Theo for 70 off geology
just go to uh
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e
forward slash
t-h-e-o that's
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e forward slash Theo
we will put uh the link in the
information
all right
um I am uh I'm grateful really uh right
now
um you know I want to talk to people
that have been through something
I want to feel something on this show
I want to talk to men and women that
have had a
that have had a walk
that a lot of others don't have
that have been through a journey
I want to talk to some miracles
you know
God's Little Easter bunnies
and um if you know someone
who
people would consider a miracle
something they've been through
um it could be anything Avalanche
uh uh electrical storm
um
anything drowning reincarnation anything
if you know somebody like that have them
hit the hotline
985-664-9503 or you can hit it and just
say hey this person but make sure that
they're cool with it
I'm not cold calling damn you know
you know I'm not going to be cold
calling a bunch of amputees or not
um
but yeah we just I want to talk to
people that have just stood right there
on the welcome mat of Heaven
or hell
and um
I want to get close to something
on this show close to something real
um and we're going to talk today to one
we got a man I'll uh I'll show a clip
from the past from um when he first
called into the show our boy Dalton
trained victim
and uh I'm looking forward uh to talking
to this man
what's going on uh my name is Dalton
I've been listening to the show off and
on for a while now if you mentioned some
of your uncle or I forget who got hit by
a train I can relate because uh when I
was in high school it was probably like
10 years ago I was actually hit by a
train
uh on the way to school I was walking to
school and I lived and uh yeah I don't
know if you want me to I can send you I
ain't gonna send me what dog
you're gonna send me some arms son I'm
just joking man wow
on the line there Dalton can you hear me
I can hear you brother what's up baby
there he is
man you're a mirror you're a miracle
brother hey living a miracle wow maybe
that little boxcar bad boy son that rail
baby
all day hey yes man dude I feel uplifted
even just seeing you man uh thanks for
joining us for a little bit today
thanks for having me yeah man so you
know you've had a really unique
experience that other people haven't had
you've been hit by a train
and it just doesn't happen to folks uh
can you take us through some of that
yeah no problem so when I was in uh it
was in high school I was in high school
about 10 years ago
and uh
when I would walk to school there was a
set of train tracks that every kid would
have to cross to get to school oh yeah
they might them risk sticks baby that's
what those are gang baby day okay sorry
for interrupting you go on as high
school you're out there you're walking
to school
yeah no problem um yeah so in my mind
I've never seen a train go by on these
train tracks it like very seldomly does
a train go by on these train tracks
and it was right after Christmas and I
got a big set of headphones for
Christmas
and uh I was walking to school and I
would know when to look up I'm what like
it's like uh across the street look both
ways but this set of trains I'm not
I'm saying you know it's
mostly my fault that this happened I'm
not blaming anybody for this but I was
looking down
with headphones on
and the train was going very slow and
when I uh think about it
if there was a camera on the situation
what had to have happened was the trains
going like this and I'm walking like
this in perfect timing I step on the
track train runs over my foot hits me in
the head
it was only two carts long so it wasn't
a long train but oh really I went
underneath that little note and then I
hit you back out sorry man you went
right under it huh yeah and then I
popped back out and then I woke up
and then somebody seen the whole
situation somebody had to flag the train
down
wow they didn't even stop what was going
on now were you um what what song were
you listening to
I was I was listening to Aussie
Revelation Mother Earth dang dang so
yeah that's kind of heavy metal
yes heavy metal on the heavy metal yeah
bro that's really wow I mean that's
almost like your ears are asking for it
they wanted that you know they wanted
the the heart the they wanted some real
percussion going on they wanted the
heavy percussion section
um were you conscious after you come out
the bottom of it
I woke up after like just beside the
tracks I woke up I spit up blood I
lifted up my leg and my leg was like
completely like just limp like
everything was shattered in there and it
was just completely lit like a tongue
almost huh basically yeah a long tongue
and so um did it knock your shoes off or
anything
see this is the weird part yeah it
knocked my shoes off and the shoes were
completely fine so I ended up wearing
those you kept wearing them well like
after I go to the hospital you know a
good pair of shoes
yeah I think I get I'd feel like I'd
burn everything but I like your attitude
you're just gonna go right back in there
and that's one thing that I really did
admire about you man was some of your
attitude I remember whenever you called
in you said that you'd been hit by a
train and some of the positive effects
that had come out of that and that if
you if you could do it again that you
would do it again you'd run it back
absolutely
um I honestly think that if somebody
could go through a near-death experience
and survive obviously very healing
process like it's almost like God you
know sat me down and said you got to
take this more seriously you know like
I you know try and live
like you know I hope for tomorrow but
you never know
yeah it's like God's saying I choo choo
choose you dog you know what I'm saying
absolutely now what are some things that
kind of happen to you like uh what are
some of the like um uplifting thoughts
and attitudes what what positives kind
of happened inside of you after that
like what adjusted if anything did
well I kind of felt like before that
like I was in high school and I was a
kid before that I was kind of like on
autopilot and you know I would just you
know I didn't know who I was and I was
just kind of on autopilot in life and
after that experience you know it really
showed me that
you know I had to come into my own
character and showed me that life is
important you know like
um made me it's a part of who I am and
it made me who I am I wouldn't change it
at all I don't know where I'd be if that
wouldn't happen if that didn't happen
wow that's really it's just such a
fascinating take on it man because I
think to be honest there's a lot of
folks out there that that are that would
like to I think get hit by a train but
aren't willing to put in the time you
know aren't willing to really you know
put their nuts on the you know in the
basket or whatever you know the ten
thousand hours yeah yeah
they're not willing to really show up
and do the work
um did it help you in any sense with the
ladies or anything that was there any
kind of did it have an effect on people
other people uh you know it is kind of a
weird situation it has been a weird
situation I am that guy that got hit by
a train hell yeah I walk into the bar oh
you're that guy that got hit by a train
I'm like yeah you know it happens
but uh
on the ladies side you know like people
are interested or like it's interesting
but you know like
I don't know it as in uh I haven't
gotten any more any less ladies because
of it I'd like to think because my
character yeah well it's funny I feel
like you and I almost look the same I
feel like you and me are some somewhat
versions of each other in some sense man
um now did it hit your penis or anything
did your body get mangled like that did
your wiener get hit out or whatever no
uh fortunately not uh it basically just
my foot you want to see it
oh yeah yeah yeah I think I do hell yeah
still this this freaks the kids out when
I show them but yeah but [ __ ] the kids
man
whoa boy damn you got that Eternal peace
sign son
so yeah I lost three toes
and this is a skin graft on top from my
leg like from uh my thigh and and the
weird part is his hair grows on this now
because it's from my leg
do I shave my foot or
hell yeah grow a little uh soul patch on
there s s o l e
dude that's phenomenal man I I love your
attitude um did it did it adjust the way
that you interact with people afterwards
did it have any effect on that I could
really see that happening well
like I said people you know I am branded
with this situation like you know
everybody knows it's like and I
understand
how crazy it is for somebody to see
somebody it's like oh they got hit by a
train but uh the way I act towards
people
is I'm always talking about you know
life and God and this and that and you
know sometimes people get uh weirded out
but you know this is this is The Game of
Life you know
yeah man important it is important do
you feel like God was reaching out to
you
absolutely
knock me off my horse and said you need
to take this game of life seriously wow
wow that's interesting do you feel like
it made you more religious it really it
really taught just you know Todd your
shoelaces directly to the Lord's you
know uh long hair
absolutely
um I don't believe in I believe all gods
are real you know whatever you believe
is real
and you know that experience made me
really feel like you know there there is
an architect there is something out
there you know planning things putting
tracks in front of things you know amen
baby all the Lord you know what I'm
gonna tell you boy let's get it dude wow
man well dude it's just you know I love
your attitude man getting to see you
I've been wanting to for a while I've
just been kind of like kind of getting
well my just taking care of myself and
um been having a lot of guests on but I
really wanted to connect back with you
man uh you've been on my mind uh just
because your attitude about saying hey
man run it back if I can have an
experience that brings me that close to
realizing the value of my existence
that I'm willing to almost do that that
there's that there must be such a value
in that huh I mean it must feel really
because you you can't just get that you
can't just create that
absolutely like I would equate it to
like maybe you know a psychedelic
experience or like it really make it
makes me at least like I don't know
anybody else in there psyche how they
would react to it but for me it makes me
feel the weight of every day um
amen and that you know this is the one
shot we only get one shot one
opportunity this is it dude mom's
spaghetti son I feel you bro well look
man I'll I'd love to check in with you
again man we'll send you some merch and
stuff like that and just uh get you
dripped out we don't have any dope ass
socks for you but uh yeah but we'll see
what we can do man and just thanks for
being alive man
um do you accredit anything inside of
you that you feel like uh
do you feel like you were the guy that
was supposed to get hit by a train if
people would have said before who's
supposed to get hit by a train you'd
think people would have picked you or
you think you just really you know just
caught that lucky uh [ __ ] long bus
you know I honestly think it was
supposed to be me man like my
mental strength like I believe that you
know I'm mentally strong not like I'm
not trying to like boast or anything but
you know this is your life look dude you
got hit by the train you guys your time
to tell us
I just I don't know if the average
person would be able to handle this and
walk away from it you know normal I
remember when they wheeled me because I
was in a wheelchair they wheeled me into
the psych ward and I'm just like they're
trying they're trying to see if I'm like
mentally this that or whatever yeah and
I'm like like I'm not having this like
you know I was it was a weird experience
but yeah it it didn't affect me funny
thing is is when I'm watching movies
with my friends and there's somebody
gets hit by a train in the movie
everybody looks to me yeah
and I'm like I'm like what guys come on
it's only it's only a train I beat that
train yeah it's one train baby yeah you
[ __ ] won I'd better come back with
something bigger you know like yeah
that's what I'm saying dude I want to
see a UFO [ __ ] land on your back son
I'm ready for a [ __ ] blimp to hit you
dog I'm afraid to tell you the Super
Bowl Led Zeppelin yeah bro I think
anything's ready bro you'll catch a
missile in your mouth son you can do
whatever you want absolutely it did make
me think of this just a second ago you
were talking about uh
would you say just a second ago before
you're talking about your first word
that wheeled me into the psych World
they tried to make you crazy yes wow
they tried to think he was like [ __ ]
or whatever because you've been hit by a
train absolutely you want to hear
something else crazy too yeah this was
at the beginning of the whole opiate
epidemic right this nurse came into the
doctors or into the hospital and she's
like we're gonna prescribe you Oxycontin
and I was like no no I smoke marijuana
for my pain yeah and then she I'll never
forget this till the day I die she's
like
Oxycontin is healthier than marijuana
wow
and it's like can I get a new nurse this
is this woman is insane like you know
this is yeah can I get this [ __ ] a
train somebody ordered this [ __ ] a
train bruh
because that's it's unbelievable that
someone that any human would think that
absolutely it was insane they were truly
selling it like
it blew my mind yeah wow
man well it's it's funny you die I mean
that that's a [ __ ] that's a dirtier
train to dodge right there man you died
absolutely wow well dude man I love your
attitude man I'd love it if we could
check in with you every now and then and
just kind of see what's going on
um where do you live at sure
um I live in uh like around Niagara
Falls Canada so like right at the border
basically that's nice it's nice up there
yeah it's nice uh Niagara Falls one of
those seven wonders of the world I'm
I've seen it so many times that it's
just normal to me but can you drink
author you can't get that close to it
pardon do I drink off can you drink off
of it if you get close to it or can you
have to stay far back yeah
that's fair I guess
um do you any of your scents is
heightened after getting hit by that
train anything do you do you feel like
you have any
unique I don't want to say Powers but
that's what people are going to want 20
hours okay do you have any unique sense
or any sense any heightened senses or
slash Powers absolutely like I was
saying like um I feel the weight of
every day
a lot more like uh I was reading this
book and there was Soldier uh it was
about soldiers in World War II
and
uh they were at the point where they
knew they were in a situation where they
knew they were gonna die there was no if
ands or buts they know they're gonna die
and because of that every moment is
sweeter the next your next meal means
everything your next
kiss means everything in the world so
and people like they these soldiers
almost like that feeling of you could
die at any moment and I don't I don't
claim to be like
you know like like a red dot on my head
like you know I'm gonna die in this
moment but I sort of feel like I you
know feel the weight of Life a lot more
you know
yeah yeah like there's just uh like it's
got us everything has a lot stronger
taste to it every every moment
absolutely wow
yeah man you're out there baby that
little rail monkey Dalton
yeah run it back two trains baby look
man
I'm proud of you dude and I'm glad to
meet you
glad to meet you too Theo you know
you're an inspiration to all of us
creatives
especially because you're a comedian and
you know you make you
you're not some glossy thing where you
you're a real person and you show us all
that we can make it be in us you know
we don't have to be this uh bigger than
life thing we could be us
well thanks man I appreciate that yeah
I'm just trying yeah I'm just it's hard
to be
anybody you know it's hard to be yeah
it's hard to be it's a real challenge it
feels like sometimes and um that's nice
you to say man I appreciate it uh
and yeah I think you do the same man you
make me feel like hey it's okay if I
only got you know
um
you know if I'm if I'm missing Toes or
I'm growing a [ __ ] uh Sideburn on my
[ __ ] foot baby let's go
well to set you up as a [ __ ] I don't
know if they make anything to cover that
brother [ __ ] missing out you should
sue them
[Laughter]
what's up thank you bro it's nice to
make your acquaintance and um when we
get up there to a show man we'll have to
have you come out and uh so you and I
can get to meet in person man absolutely
I've been waiting for you to come to
Canada man yeah we'll get up there soon
my tour manager is from Ontario London
Ontario okay yeah that's I've been there
that's close so um he'll get me up in
that area soon man but uh but yeah we'll
do something nice then we'll send you
one of these bobble heads dude and get
you out there and get you some some
items or something that you want and uh
just thank you bro thank you for sharing
yourself with us and um [ __ ] yeah dude
if somebody get hit by a train and just
keep on just Trucking then I can do that
today you know so thank you dog
love you Theo love you too speed one
love amen baby you're a miracle thanks
Dalton thank you
a miracle right there
a miracle
and we got to listen to him
and we got to learn from them
man I'm grateful for that today
it's a real perspective switch you know
it's a real perspective switch
it makes my problem I mean
my problems seemed like Micro Machines
right there
when you got a fella that's just damn
that's just getting trained out
man
grateful to be alive today
um grateful to exist on this planet
um
working on staying in gratitude myself
you know
still battling some anger here and there
and
um
some I don't know if it's ego or just
you know thinking things are supposed to
be a certain way expectation
you know I'd love to not approach the
day with a lot of expectation
I'd love to just
sit there and watch God paint
you know
but usually I want to get up and I want
to open up this color in this color and
you know I'll see what he does I'm only
giving him four colors you know
I'm giving him this brush I want the
wide bro I want
instead of just sitting back and saying
all right
let me see what magic
this big dog
is gonna do with the canvas of my life
you know
what's he gonna paint what's he gonna
put out there
and just not to look for the end product
but to enjoy the uh
the colors along the way
um
you guys be good to yourselves man you
deserve it you can hit the hotline
985-664-9503 I know we owe a couple
calls about some anger a gentleman that
called in a while back about anger he
was dealing with and I want to get some
response calls for him didn't get to it
today
um but we will in the future
um thank you guys for supporting my
podcast and being a part of my life
um
yeah
I think that's all we got today
love y'all man gang
[Music]
this is uh
whenever you're down out in the cold
there is a lights
by the stone keepers
David Manuel
[Music]
walk with me
[Music]
there is a light shining for you
guiding your way
[Music]
I love that hit but you know what man
that's not getting me all the way there
I'm gonna finish out the way we came in
baby
you know
[Music]
I've been so blue
I'm gonna come up
it feels so good I have a brand new view
s
[Music]
You're Gonna Come
and it's waiting to see but when are you
and me we got so much love and in
chemistry it's gonna come up
[Music]
well good things
[Music]
[Music]